[Music]
so
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
[Music]
week seven man this season is flying
happy nfl sunday everybody you just
tapped into the br betting squad ride
live in the bleacher report app
presented by draftkings my name is
connor rogers alongside mr winner's only
greg ivory greg how we feeling are we
feeling generous today
hey man
christmas is coming
halloween season is upon us i mean we're
giving out candy and we gonna be giving
out gifts why not give out hoodies right
now right connor that's right why not
give out hoodies right now why not right
now i'm in the comments first off
first off connor i'm so sorry i gotta
introduce the new people to the show and
the and the people that come back to the
show the fables this is right here i
gotta introduce you guys this is right
here the handy dandy ipad this is how
you get your hoodies this is how you get
your jerseys this is how you get tapped
into the show i'm in the handy dandy and
i see jt mvp 0 jamar chase is a lot to
score he's on my fantasy team i love
that take shout out to you jt for mvp
zero you are walking away with a hoodie
connor let's get this thing going man
reunited and it feels so good man it's
good to see you back with the ipad not
the iphone i feel like it's going to be
popping off a little bit more today this
is the show where we want to bet anytime
touchdown scorers and that's why we ask
you on social we ask you in the app who
are your locks of the week to get into
the end zone for week 7 on this nfl
sunday
man let's take a look at the most
popular picks you've sent us
i mean no surprise at the top right
alvin kamara devonte adams travis kelsey
you see those three names on this show
every single week aaron jones who's had
a three touchdown game this year dj
moore taking on that giant secondary
that our squad ride leader cooper cup
ate up last week lamar jackson the
former mvp we know what he can do on the
ground joe mixon for those surprising
bengals and then man plus 240 on the
bottom of the board zach ertz people
might be feeling good about his new
destination in arizona with another mvp
front runner and kyler murray and cliff
kingsbury so a lot of fun touchdown
scorers on the board today and to get
things started here let's take a look at
some of our favorite lock legend videos
from last week
you know we in home depot with it man
trying to get you guys a lock for the
anytime touchdown score we got three
bulls each little peanut butter our
judge steve
[Applause]
all right
aaron jones plus 110 lock it in boys
let's ride
oh [ __ ] what is this anytime touchdown
score a lot kareem hunt let's hammer
that boys
cooper cup former eastern eagle
guaranteed versus the giants
all right craig tell the people what
you're hooking them up with today
i'm not only giving out hoodies today
connor i'm also giving away two not one
but two nfl jerseys one goes out to the
winning lock legend and the other goes
to a lucky commenter like you so don't
go anywhere stay tapped in get in the
comments do what you do if you need a
jersey if you need a hoodie i need gifts
i need emojis but most importantly i
need winners only please actually put
that you guys flood the comments with
winners only please i'm giving out a
hoodie to somebody i see that says
winners only please
let's go connor let's go let's get into
it and with that being said speaking of
those locks we have four legendary picks
to show you the last one standing will
be our week seven squad ride leader
let's not waste time let's get into it
first pitch comes from john hertl tell
us who's scoring a touchdown today john
blackjack is a lock
and so is
devonta adams to score a touchdown week
7 nfl let's go
the blackjack legend going with devonte
adams i like that setup all right first
decision of the day first challenge of
the day let's get our second pitch from
nick jones 3005.
let's go baby be our betting here i am
at the tree of knowledge
sunday will be the anniversary of the
planting of the tree of knowledge so you
know it's about to give me some locks
here it is right here
all of its gloriousness
let me pull down a leaf real quick
oh what's that
dj moore anytime touchdown
let's go baby all right you've heard the
first two pitches you got devonte adams
from the blackjack legend then you got
the tree of knowledge going with dj
moore greg you feeling strong about
either of these
uh connor i
don't know let me tap in with the people
what i need you guys to do is get in the
comments and tell me who we should ride
with davonte adam dj more but first and
most importantly i asked you guys to say
winners only please conor in the
comments are flooding with winners only
please but a bollinger a bollinger 333
shout out to you he got the rock uh he
got the rock lifting up the people's
champion saying winners only please you
were walking away with a hoodie connor i
want to talk about the tree of knowledge
here love the video love the video he he
he beeped it up really really well a
cinematic piece in fact loved the video
the pic
don't really love it like how i love the
devante adams play here uh just kind of
confused kind of confused as how black
jack he has 21 it looks like he has 19.
how does that add up to 17 that that
doesn't add up to 17 and devonte adams
but he's not confused about the pick
aaron rodgers he's he looks at 17 a lot
throughout the game so i love my chances
of him scoring a touchdown and you know
what we can do here connor you know what
we can do here it says minus 165 but it
won't stay like that it will not stay
like that connor which way are you
leaning i'm with you all the way let's
go with the target monster and devonta
adams let's get that minus 165 a little
bit closer to even money i think the
comments would love that and man right
now greg i just don't trust sam darnold
to get dj moore into the end zone even
against a weak giants team i don't think
that's a lot but when you look at
devonte adams and aaron rodgers every
week that's as close to a lock as things
get no matter what those odds say
but hey i don't get to decide this round
let's let the people decide it what are
they thinking right now
connor i am back into the handy dandy
back into the handy dandy i got uh
i oh neck man 42 he's spamming us he's
spamming us neckman42 says dj is a lock
okay uh shout out to you neck man shot
no hoodie for the spam no hoodie for the
spam uh but shout out to you love the
pick i got
devonte adams locking in winners only
let's go baby lock ken dog 2320 ken
three is spelled k3n that's to the
producers kendall 2320 damonte adams is
a lock you're walking away with a hoodie
i'm gonna give away one more connor one
more
one more here we go it's a lot of
devonte adams i'll just be honest i see
a lot of devante adams and here we go jj
snell jj snell says adams adams adams
shout out to you jj snell you are
walking away with the hoodie connor it
appears it is very apparent in the
comments if you look at them uh it's
devontae all the way so i guess the
blackjack legend devonte adams and john
hurdle is moving on to the next round
yeah it feels like we have a blowout
first round belongs to john hertl two
challengers remaining though so he's got
a long way to go and our next pitch
comes from w trammell a familiar face on
this show always brings the heat who you
got w trammell
vr nation we're here with the anytime
touchdown sport see if we can hit one of
these boards
marks
the axe throwing legend loving lamar
jackson you know we love lamar jackson
on this show
greg
can this get you off that devonta adams
pick what do you think here
oh absolutely
connor do you see that plus 125 lamar
jack we're talking about nice guys
mvp mvp candidate lamar jackson we know
it's rushing but we know what lamar does
he can sling it and he also can run the
ball uh they're taking on cincinnati
taking on cincinnati i can see this one
being a high score in the fair and uh
i will take my chances conor if lamar
jackson has plus money to score a
touchdown rushing i'm taking those
chances and you know what we can do here
so uh
i think i'm going to lean towards this
plus money although devonte is a safer
pick
which way are you riding connor i'm
trailing you let's take a little bit
more of a risk here let's go with some
crazier odds i think lamar plus 125 and
division game when he always puts the
team on his back in those big moments
the bengals are no pushover this year
they are going to be a tough team they
are not going to just lay over and die
in this game which means lamar is going
to have to do a little extra you see
what that backfield looks like i mean
le'veon bell elevated from the practice
squad again that's where we're at in
baltimore i like lamar to get in the end
zone we did it last week we got the
commenters to follow us on that cooper
cup train what did he do he'd score once
he scored twice let's do it again lamar
jackson come for the ride what are the
people thinking right now
come on hey connor you just preached it
is sunday it is sunday and it is morning
church is in service i mean connor you
just preach to the people and they're
all
rocking with lamar jackson they're all
rocking with lamar jackson i see uh
rolling hard 45 easy come on lamar
jackson gift go white sox jackson is
cooking into the end zone winners only
please
lj all day jack jack boy zoe 12 18.
connor you just spoke the word and the
people is responding uh it appears shout
out to everybody that i just mentioned
i'll give out one more i'll give out one
more why not jimmy16
jimmy16 he's he's rocking with devante
adams but we show no discrimination here
you are walking away with honey but the
people have spoken we are riding with
lamar jackson the axe legend and my guy
w trammell to move on to the next round
yeah we are in this together second
round belongs to w trammell he's got one
more contender to take on this where
things get interesting you want to take
home that jersey you want to be the
squad ride leader for week number seven
winner of this round takes all let's get
into it next up chase howard zero let's
see that pick chase
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
my man making a complete mess on that
staircase and going with travis
kelsey man we got a good match up here
right kelsey's always a favorite on this
show and we show that leaderboard at the
top lamar the guy just gets it done week
after week
greg axe legend staircase legend he feel
strongly about either one what do we got
here
this this one's this one's tough connor
this one's tough what i need everybody
to do
get in the comments and let us know this
is the last round we rock it with travis
kelsey we rock it with lamar jackson
we're 3-0 in the last three weeks man we
got to keep this train
going we got to keep this train going uh
connor
i got a question for the people in the
comments i got a question for you and i
want you guys to reply to me in the
comments and let me know and i'm giving
out a hoodie but i want to know the over
under attempts it took the stair legend
to actually make this video i'm going to
set the line at uh let's say seven let's
say seven you guys tell me over under in
the comments connor you think it went
over under over way too many is your
answer that that probably took and
that's okay right all right when you
look at this travis kelsey has scored
once in the last four weeks and he's
still at minus
titans defense not good chiefs gotta be
hungry kelsey he's gotta get in the end
zone today that being said those minus
odds greg i'm sticking with lamar here i
like the plus odds i know the magic you
can work to bump those things up where
are the comments at right now to decide
the squad ride leader
comments are all over the place comments
are actually i see i see some kelsey so
i'll give off some hoodies here we go
jack zaman's jack zaman says travis
kelsey shout out to you zach
i see trash trash is in the comments
saying lamar is a lock shout out to you
trash uh raymond raymond of facts 22
raymond facts 22 says travis kelsey
uh i see lamar
brad
shortman brad shortman says lamar all
right connor it's back and forth and
also i see the people saying over
they're saying over in the comments so
i'm gonna give out
shaq 223 shaq223 i don't think i said
your name today but shaq 223 you're
walking away with a hoodie for the
overtake but connor um the next one i
see because the comments are back and
forth the next one i see we're just
going to call it the winner all right
the next one i see we're going to call
it the winner and we got e-j-w-y-n-317
saying lamar jackson is a lock so that
means connor
the axe legend lamar jackson and our guy
w trammell is the winner of
the squad ride this week shout out to uw
tremolo shout out to you uh axe legend
and shout out to the people that rode
with him can i see the graphic please so
i can show the people what we can do
here you guys see lamar jackson is at
plus 125. let me show you guys some
magic poof
there it is there it is there it is plus
165. thanks to our friends at draftkings
we're going to boost that for you guys
we're going to do that for you guys
we're going to take it from plus 125 to
plus 165 check be our betting social for
a link to the odds send us your
screenshots of your bets let's get rich
this sunday send us your videos and your
celebration
we want winners
and winners only
please
all right everyone come along for the
ride make some money let's get lamar in
the end zone love those boosted odds
greg we're not done yet got more locks
you still got a jersey to give away
it's time for the comment contest we do
this every week if you hang out in the
br betting community stream in the br
app you know we asked you this week how
many yards will patrick mahomes throw
for against that titans defense we
picked two of our favorite comments now
let's not forget the line is set at
328.5
greg let's take a look at what the
people are thinking of the comments we
chose for my home's passing yards
yes sir what i need everybody to do
though before we do that just get in the
comments and tell me how many yards
you think mahomes is throwing for
after the game we'll pick one person who
guessed correctly or who gets the
closest actually and we're gonna hook
you up with the swag bag from br betting
let's take a look at the first comment
from so bond 18.
there it is sobond says since they won't
be able to stop king henry he will need
to put up 380
to
382
i don't i mean we're not talking about
pat mahomes here yeah we're talking
about pat mahomes here that 382 seems
light to me conor which way or which way
are you leaning like is that a lot or a
little it's not as crazy as people are
going to think in 2019 the last time you
saw the titans in the regular season he
threw for 446 right i know things have
been different in the playoffs but 446
the last time he saw gravel in the
regular season and they need him to do
this greg they need him to go towards
400 passing yards in this game to keep
up with that titan's ground attack so
i don't think it's crazy at all
what's the other comment leaning a
little under way under where we at with
the next one here
let's take a look at the next comments
from val v 56 valve v56 says
two no he says
336 passes a little lower for my homes
and taking home
the l connor don't forget about the
second part and taking home the l 336 is
real life 336 is real life i don't know
about the l i'm actually staying away
from the game but i like the total i
like the total see this as a high
scoring game connor what is your take on
my guy val v's uh comment i like it both
comments went over right the line was
328.5 valve going just a little bit over
that and i think that's closer right 382
would it shock me because it's mahomes
no do i think we're looking at somewhere
between 330 and 345 i think that's more
realistic and they're gonna have to do
it once again to stay in this game i
know we're kind of trolling them there
or laughing saying he's gonna have to
hold the l after the game i i don't bet
against patrick mahomes i'm with you
greg this is a really dicey game with a
really bizarre line and the chiefs love
to run it up when they get a lead but
can they against derek henry that's what
we don't know what do the people think
of all this right now
connor i'm seeing a lot of yards a lot
of yards from the people uh
they're referring to my guy uh patrick
mahomes we got jack zayman's 327 yards
bring home the w at pierce is that under
327 that falls a yard under barely
barely
barely okay shout out to you jack
zaman's uh you were walking away with a
hoodie positive vibes only i love this
comment connor positive vibes only
mahomes with the dub and 412 yards
jersey or bus 2021 you are a legend
jersey or bus 2021 you are walking away
with the hoodie the two people that i
said you guys are walking away with a
hoodie i don't know about the l connor i
don't know about the o and the audience
likes a higher number
i'm looking at i see 417 417 uh i see
428 that the audience likes a high
number so we're gonna go with sobon
we're gonna go with sobon18 as the
winner of the comments contest so bond
you are walking away with a hoodie and
remember after the game we'll pick one
person who gets the closest and hook you
up with the swag bag so fill those
comments up keep guessing because
you might have a chance to win a swag
bag
all right we can't close out the show
without our boldest bets we got to get
back on track here boldest bets every
week let's get crazy let's go for those
long shots
greg let the people know what we got in
store here
okay get in the comments and let me know
if you're riding with me or if you're
riding with my guy connor my guy connor
has hit a couple of these he's hit a cup
release he's hit a couple of these so
connor
talk to the people tell him what do you
got we're growing with josh jacobs this
week a guy that he can score in bunches
and i think against the eagles who have
given up a lot against running backs
this year i think this is the week for
josh jacobs he even said it this week he
finally feels his best he finally feels
like injuries aren't bringing him down
he feels healthy he feels right this is
a team that wants to run the football
plus 6 50. what
for a workhorse running back
i don't know i maybe i'm too optimistic
last half full sunday morning who knows
what it is josh jacobs plus 650 get in
the endzone twice let's make it happen
greg what do you got in store
connor i'm gonna take a play out of your
old playbook brother
i'm gonna take a play out of your old
playbook and i'm gonna go with my guy
tyreek hill to score two or more
touchdowns in this week's matchup
against the tennessee titans we talked
about this connor we talked about it a
high score in the fair i said i like the
total i like the over you talked about
it you said it's going to be a high
scoring affair
so why not
tyree go get two that's one of patrick
mahomes comfort blankets it's him or
travis kelsey uh tyree go out there and
do what you do connor ran this play like
a couple weeks ago with the hit so let's
run it back let's run it back
i think that's on the money honestly
against that titans defense we saw
plenty of receivers kind of eat them up
this year i don't think you're crazy at
all yes all right two things we need for
you greg before we get out of here and
watch some football we need you one to
let us know who the people are rocking
with and two the most important of this
show you got a jersey to give away
got a jersey to give away got a jersey
to give away up
chris paul goat chris paul goat says
josh jacobs is a lock he's rocking with
you connor let's go rocking with you
shout out to you chris paul goat uh you
are walking away from a hoodie
uh here we go uh
jesse balanos jesse balano's riding with
greg let's get that w let's go tyrique
let's get that w so the comments are
back and forth they're showing both of
us love connor they're showing both of
us love
but it's time it is time to give away
that jersey uh
it's time to give away that jersey i'm
in the comments right now looking for a
take
looking for a take uh here we go
the comments are rocking rocking all
right here we go we smith 44 wii smith
44 says rocking with g money and tyreke
the the the cheetah hill
has a lot of emojis
has a lot of fire emojis and a lot of
money emojis so shout out to you we
smith for your emojis and your take and
rockaway uh my guy tyree kill you are
walking away with a jersey of your
choice shout out to you
man i'm excited for this week i feel
good about the long shot bets both of
them might hit that would be pretty hot
on this show good luck with your wagers
everyone let's make some money today
congrats all our hoodie and jersey
winners if you won you are betting is
going to dm you in the next 24 hours
have no fear thank you to everyone that
commented thank you to the lock legends
john hertle nick jones w trammell chase
howard bringing the heat with those
videos enjoy your football sunday drop
your real time takes in the betting
community streaming the vr whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa connor got
something left before we get out of here
i gotta give out one more brother gotta
give out one more for those jason wade
jason wade says jason wade 13 says greg
love the pig but tyrique is not fully
healthy let's go with connor
shout out to you jason wade you're
rocking with my guy connor you are
walking away with a hoodie i love
carter's pick actually you stick around
you show a little love to both picks you
might just win alongside greg ivory my
name is connor rogers see you next week
same time same place let's go 4-0 in the
last four weeks goodbye everyone
yes sir
[Music]
foreign